definitely seems like a wild and fun
thing to make
so how did it come your way i mean
what were you told about it what was the
pitch like what sort of tagline were you
given when this came your way because it
seems like it's very hard to describe
well i've known donovan leech a long
time and he's one of the producers on it
one of the main producers on it and
he just contacted me and and and um
i've done things up with him over the
years but he asked me to come and meet
janelle and we went to the chateau malmo
and i read this and i i read the script
and i couldn't you know i really enjoyed
it and i sort of enjoyed the obviously
everyone goes to their own part first
you know like scan it see how much
you're in it and what what's the what's
the dialogue like and i liked it and i
thought it was super spirited and
spunky and i liked eric i liked my
character for the kind of
human
basic human errors and
sad fall from grace and just like messy
life um
i found that interesting you know it's
more interesting than sort of like a
buff superhero stuff you know i thought
it was like cool and um
and and i met matt janelle and she was
just a lot of fun and just
was just all she wanted to talk about
was the art direction of the sex club
they were going to shoot at which was
nothing to do with my character so i was
like okay i like this girl she's a
little crazy
and um
it was a wonder you know really fun
experience i mean i enjoyed it i mean
it's just it's hard work for everyone
when those those indie movies uh
but
i think bella is fantastic uh great to
work with and
you know paris is just as a movie star
herself and um amazing and i got to meet
jamie
hintz who i love from the kills and so
we worked together on that and so it
just was a
all these different reasons to make it
work and all these different reasons for
it to be a a good time and um i can't
wait to see i haven't seen the finished
film so i don't even know what kind of
ended up in there so part of me is a bit
cautious because
i felt like i super went for it so i
don't know how much of my going for it
actually made the uh made the baby cut
you know
when you're acting in scenes with a
fellow musician
like jamie i mean were there is there
sort of an unspoken thing that you share
with each other and at the same time
could you have ever imagined that you
would be acting in a movie together as a
collaboration as opposed to something
music related
no i mean first of all as i say i love i
love his band he's a really really
talented guy
and i really you know i it's hard for me
to find bands consistently
with lyrics that i love and
i
love the kills from the get-go
um
fried my little brains all the way
through to the last record you know so
uh what was funny is that
you know you don't i didn't want to spam
anybody because they were there to act
and he was originally an actor before he
was a musician so
i think he was so excited to play to be
in a movie um
[Music]
and uh we played off of that you know
and
it was only the end of working together
what was saying goodbye swapping numbers
and all that that i was like i gotta say
you know i just love your band you know
i didn't i didn't let on for a few days
because
it just seemed weird we weren't in that
zone and uh
so but it was it was brilliant to do
that and uh he was going off to make a
new record uh but i don't know any
collaboration there but i'd be open to
it he's amazing
your character finds himself in a rather
compromising position with his character
and with queenie
how was it to shoot that whole sequence
tied and bound like that i mean do you
just sort of have to mentally get to a
zen place when you're gonna be stuck
like that for a bit
i mean to me the you know the someone
asked me earlier about the link between
uh music and acting and i think the most
important thing in any
performance based work or any anything
creative you know you just have to lose
yourself so for me i just
let go and and um
you know i think there's an actor when i
first began acting and i did some
studying when i was young and you know
it was good for me because i was a
little uptight or very uptight i was a
very shy person and i kind of did this
acting course
at a at a a place city lit in london
uh for professional access a refresher
course just to kind of almost like crack
my shell crack my exterior i felt like i
was just
you know i hadn't come up through any
kind of encouraging parenthood you know
oh you're great or your picasso which i
mean nothing like that so
i think i was a little bit like wary and
and uptight you know like my kids now
they have you see youtube star so
they're just amazing on camera you video
them they're like hey we gotta they're
so loose it's incredible so i think it's
all about finding a way to be loose and
finding a way to just be open and uh
that's what i did
you talked about you mentioned your kids
do you listen to music with your kids
what what have you taught them about the
music you love and listen to and what do
they teach you from music that they
listen to
well you gotta be careful i mean i don't
i don't see i just play stuff i don't i
don't say you gotta listen to that
obviously for me it's interesting
because
i hear
them hearing the kind of the kind of
fourth in line from where it began you
know oh if you like this you're gonna
read it like that band so sometimes i've
done that where i might play them the
first band the original bad like you
know my eldest son was getting into a
lot of you know green day and
that that sort of pop punk and so i just
make sure i just play some sex pistols
make sure i play the clash make sure i
play x-ray specs
and show them where this those bands
with the original
versions of those bands and
um
that's as far as i go you know because
you got to be careful i mean you know
people claim
people as their own for their generation
you know and and you don't want to be
like an old fart going like ah that's no
good sometimes i i find it a bit
difficult with some people who just
they're not very good and i think the
originals are better
so all i do is just play the original
and
you know you gotta let them they've gone
through super heavy hip hop phase like
really
crazy stuff where i'm just like man it
works you know like
it just when a lot of the sort of bad
language this is really confusing for
kids because they hear that and then
they think it's okay to speak like that
when it's really not so that's a bit of
a dilemma any kind of jumping on the
thing when it starts getting super like
you know really um overtly aggressive
and
and uh
that stuff is a bit challenging but
generally you gotta let them be and
you know i think it's a natural thing i
think it's more like
for me i mean i what do i know but i
think that kids is like mirroring you
just behave a certain way and you act a
certain way it's not like i don't want
to be an annoying frequency that's
always like correcting and chastising
and being annoying i mean i'm a musician
i'm a musician and like i have kids as
well it's not like i'm a you know
that sort of tiny dad so
i um i just try and behave well and my
kids are really really polite and
they're really funny and after that it's
all gravy i think
i know you previously talked about how
you've written a movie with janelle
what can you say about that movie how
did that happen what was that experience
like to write a movie
uh was just this this this idea that i
had is like a love story in reverse it's
like a horror love story
a love story that goes wrong and um
it's so dark and so violent
that uh
i rang up janelle asking i wanted to get
a a girl writer to help me and i asked
her
to make sure that i had a very really
strong woman's voice in it you know
because i think that's really important
nowadays not least when you look at
what's happening in afghanistan
uh so strong women you know um it's a
time for everyone to realize how strong
women are and as the world as we as it
evolves that's what we celebrate and so
she i told her the idea and stuff she's
like oh my god i wanna oh i'm gonna
direct that so
she's doing that and we've got uh a
friend of hers angie sims who's a
screenwriter who's uh i meet with
tomorrow
to go another round of like the fourth
draft
so
that's just a really good experience and
just i know it's a bit like billy bob
thornton yeah i mean you want to be in a
great movie but no one's gonna you know
i have been cast in this but it's quite
difficult to get cast in movies you know
i mean that they're
people are so specific what they want
and
it's quite hard you know um so i
basically wrote a movie i could be in a
lot
does that have a title
yeah it's called the edge of nowhere
oh you've been doing some acting work
for some time now did you have a moment
or a project where you really felt like
an actor and like you knew what that
meant as far as the craft of it all goes
well
you know yeah towards the end usually
towards the end of the process on my
last few days and now i'm feeling all
ready and ready to go like an olympic
actor you know and then there's no you
know
you know i sort of fail this audition
fail that audition you know
um
and i've gone up for a couple of good
things but and i thought i did pretty
good audition because now you have to
self tape so i was like
okay i'm not going to take this
personally that's just not type because
that was you know those words sound real
you know
so
i don't know i i i never feel that good
at anything
um i think that's a secret to my
longevity is that i i'm always fighting
to get better i think that the day that
i feel accomplished and assured and
overconfident is the day that it all
dries up you know what i mean so i think
that that humility
and desire to be better is a is a
cornerstone of my entire creative life
this film has such interesting diverse
female voices with it from the director
to
bella thorne to josie ho
what was it like to work with bella and
with josie and how did they compare his
team partners because they both very
much seem all in you're so right you're
so right well also we had this girl rain
who was the cinematographer so it was
very strong i was very happy and proud
to be
on a movie with a
first-time female director with a female
camera woman who'd had a lot of
experience from hong kong
a great girl great woman
rain and um
you know to me acting is all about with
other people it's how you react and how
you make it real you know and uh that's
what to me is the most mesmerizing thing
about actors how they bring word to life
and how you believe in them they create
these worlds
and so with bella i had this incredible
experience where she's so self-assured
she's incredibly charismatic and really
really good
and just
i mean quite masterful i mean she's what
23 24 23 or something 24. and i think
she's probably had about 22 years of
experience and
so she just brings a confidence that is
just
really it's it's beautiful to watch and
i enjoyed her she's a lot of power
and um and then with jamie it was
interesting because he was just
it was his first movie so even though
he's trained as an actor i think that he
was
second guessing himself quite a bit and
so when we were rehearsing
the way we work it just was it just it
just seemed to work because you know
things he did that were great really
resonated and then he kept with those
and so that was a whole different
thing you know with bella you working
with this like incredible experience
with jamie something different and with
josie she's just sort of like slightly
she's you know she's slightly bonkers
you know she's got an amazing big
personality the whole time you know i
mean and so her husband was there i
remember saying
she's amazing a little crazy but she's
amazing and she always likes always
always always like this and so she
brought this crazy energy like the the
scene where um
uh i think the hostage scene
they came in and josie's got this really
animated big energy and jamie's a bit
more kind of uh laid-back and cool and
like you know more street and they both
had different versions of the script
so
you know it was all they were already at
complete odds then they had a complete
script so you can imagine an indie movie
is like i was like [ __ ] okay who's who's
gonna does jamie have to appropriate to
her version she had oh she she didn't
have a up-to-date version of script so
of course that puts jamie you're like
freaked out now he's worked on it you
know so all that stuff
i think is brilliant you know feeds into
it and i'm gagged so i'm like trying to
try to help
because i knew the lines because i'd
read them so much that i knew everyone's
lines and so
it was that gave it its own energy you
know i mean that suddenly you got that
energy in there that you can't you don't
realize the frenetic energy of people
not knowing which script to follow at
that point
it's genius you know that's like man ray
at its finest
well the last thing i would ask you that
constantine is a movie that has a lot of
fans and they all really love the film
and talk about how much they love the
film
with everything that you've accomplished
in music and and now in acting are you
surprised that that's the project that
people talk about with you so much was
there a time that you realized that this
movie was going to follow you no matter
what else you did i i i don't think
about that i mean i love it i mean
people do come up to me with different
you know
i mean i get plenty of love for the
other stuff as well but for sure for the
acting
people love that the biggest
confusion i have is how they making like
17 versions of every other movie and
constantine doesn't get like a sequel
and when i did the um
i did the song for john wick and so i
saw keanu
um
whatever it was a couple years ago when
that came out
and i said to him
i was like what why is there no
constantine secretly because i guess it
didn't make enough money i was like ah
that whole little commerce thing so
i think that if enough people you know
show more love maybe we'll get a sequel
because i think it'd be so that was a
lot of fun to do and uh who knows what
the hell was going on that film but it
was amazing i love doing it
yeah it's one of those movies that
people ask all the time about why there
isn't a sequel if there'll ever be a
sequel it's it's one of them
it's ridiculous it's so silly such a
shame you know you think of all the
terrible sequels that come out yeah
you know
life that's art for you you know i mean
yeah well thank you for talking to me
about everything i i just this movie is
wild so thank you so much
thank you